THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE'RE HOLDING OUR HEARING
TODAY IN ROOM 112 OF THE STATE
CAPITOL. IT'S A BUSY MORNING,
AND MANY OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE ALSO NEEDED IN OTHER
COMMITTEES THAT ARE ALSO MEETING
AT THE SAME TIME. BUT WE WOULD
STILL LIKE TO HAVE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM AS SOON AS THEY CAN
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE
HAVE FOUR MEASURES ON TODAY'S
AGENDA, AND SINCE WE ARE PAST
THE FISCAL DEADLINE, WE CANNOT
MOVE MEASURES TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. ALL MEASURES BEING HEARD
TODAY WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR A Dð
PASS MOTION. BEFORE WE BEGIN, I
WANT TO REMIND ANY WITNESSES TO
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY
POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND REPEATING
PRIOR TESTIMONY IN YOUR
COMMENTS. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS LET US KNOW THAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE FILES FOR ANY
OF THE MEASURES BEING HEARD
TODAY, SO THEY WILL NOT BE
PROVIDING COMMENTS ON THE BILLS.
WE'RE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE, AND WE HAVE THE
APPROVAL OF THE REPUBLICANS ON
THE COMMITTEE TO BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND AS THEY GET
HERE, WE'LL TAKE UP THE VOTES.
SO WE'LL START TODAY WITH AB 224
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO,
WHICH IS ELIGIBLE FOR A Dð PASS
MOTION. WELCOME GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
PROUD TO JOIN SENATOR UMBERG IN
AUTHORING AB 224, WHICH WOULD
EXTEND THE NEW NEWS CARRIERS
EXEMPTION FROM AB FIVE UNTIL
2030. I AM THANKFUL TO OUR
FORMER ASSEMBLY LABOR CHAIR FOR
HIS MOST RECENT EFFORTS, WHICH
THIS MEASURE SIMPLY EXTENDS. THE
NEWSPAPER PROFESSION CONTINUES
TO FACE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
RESULTING FROM LOSS AND AD
REVENUE TO TECH GIANTS, WHILE
TRANSITIONING TO DIGITAL
PLATFORMS AND A DECLINE IN
SUBSCRIPTIONS. THESE REASONS,
COMPOUNDED WITH THE UNIQUE
STRUCTURE IN WHICH CARRIERS
CONTRACT WITH MULTIPLE
PUBLISHERS, PLACES STRESS ON THE
INDUSTRY, WHICH IS NOT SEEN
ELSEWHERE. HENCE WHY WE ARE HERE
TODAY. BY PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
TIME FOR THIS TRANSITION, JOBS
FOR JOURNALISTS, JOURNALISTS,
EDITORS AND NEWSPAPER PRODUCTION
WORKERS WILL BE PROTECTED WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY SUPPORTING THE
CURRENT AGE OF NEWS MEDIA. WITH
ME TODAY, I HAVE BRITTANY
BARSOTTI ON BEHALF OF OUR
SPONSOR, THE CALIFORNIA
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS, TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, AS WELL
AS JORGE CAMACHO IS WITH ME
HERE, HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF A
POPULAR NEWSPAPER OF
BAKERSFIELD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IF YOU IF YOUR WITNESS WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN
REGARDS TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS OF
IT. IF NOT, WE'LL WE'LL MOVE ON
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS. SORRY. IT'S ALL GOOD.
IT'S ALL GOOD. I'M THE PUBLISHER
OF EL POPULAR. WE'RE A SMALL
PUBLICATION IN BAKERSFIELD,
CALIFORNIA, AND WE ARE OF
GENERAL CIRCULATION. AND RIGHT
NOW I'M IN SUPPORT OF AN
EXTENSION ON AB 224. I THINK
THAT WILL GIVE US A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME KIND OF TO TRANSITION
INTO THE DIGITAL FORMAT THAT
WE'RE IN SEARCH OF RIGHT NOW. A
LOT OF PUBLISHERS ARE
CONTRACTING WITH COMPANIES THAT
DISTRIBUTE MULTIPLE PUBLICATIONS,
AND THAT ACTUALLY PROVIDES A
SERVICE TO THEM, THE READER.
OKAY BUT AT THE SAME TIME, IT
CREATES A BURDEN TO THE
PUBLISHERS. AND I THINK ONE
INDEPENDENT CARRIER CAN BENEFIT
FROM AN EXTENSION OF AB 224
DOING THE SAME SERVICE TO THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE. SO AT
THIS TIME, I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON 224. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LOVE
YOUR PUBLICATION. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE?
SEEING NONE, YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
AND WHEN WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL
TAKE IT UP. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND FOR
REMINDING ME THAT WE STARTED AT
NINE. THANK YOU. NEXT UP IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, WHO IS
NOT HERE. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 535
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHABOT.
AGAIN, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A Dð
PASS MOTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. SO CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE GREAT STRIDES IN REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF VETERANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
RECENTLY, THIS MONTH, FEDERAL
REGULATORY CHANGES HAVE EXCLUDED
VETERAN DISABILITY BENEFITS FROM
INCOME CALCULATIONS FOR
DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY FOR
VETERANS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
VOUCHERS. THIS CHANGE ALIGNS
WITH FEDERAL REGULATIONS. AND SO
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY
ADDITIONAL HOUSING TO BE BUILT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT ALSO IS A
HUGE COST SAVINGS BECAUSE OF THE
SIMPLIFIED INCOME VERIFICATION
PROCESS. AS A RESULT, AB. 535 IS
A NECESSARY AND SIMPLE FIX THAT
WILL CLEAR THE WAY FOR OBSTACLES
AND CLEAR AWAY ANY OBSTACLES TO
GETTING VETERANS INTO NEEDED
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NOT WITH US HERE
TODAY, SO WE'LL ASK WHETHER OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE, YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. AND WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE UP THE BILL.
IT IS A Dð PASS MOTION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU CAN. GREAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS AB 1034 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREYSON. AGAIN
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A Dð PASS
MOTION. SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND AB
1034 EXTENDS THE EXEMPTION
SUNSET DATE FOR LAWSUITS
ORIGINATED UNDER THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ACT. WE KNOW
AS PAGA FOR CONTRACTORS IN THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
THAT ARE PARTY TO A VALID
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
THAT MEETS SPECIFIED CRITERIA
AND HAVE NEGOTIATED WITH THEIR
LOCAL UNION TO INCLUDE THE
WAIVER IN THEIR CBA. SO THE
STATUTE DOES NOT ALTER A LOCAL
UNION'S ABILITY TO DECIDE TO
INCLUDE OR NOT INCLUDE PAGA. THE
PAGA WAIVER IN THEIR CBA WITH
THAT 1034 AGAIN EXTENDS ALLOWS
WORKERS uCONTINUE TO BENEFIT
FROM THE IMPORTANT EXEMPTION BY
EXTENDING THE SUNSET TO 2038,
SUPPORTED BY MULTIPLE LABOR
CONTRACTOR GROUPS. AND I DO HAVE
A WITNESS HERE TODAY AS WELL.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON.
DANNY CURTIN, CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF CARPENTERS. MADAM
CHAIR, WELCOME. SO I'M GOING TO
ADDRESS THE FISCAL ASPECTS TO
TAKE ABOUT 30S. SOUNDS GOOD. SO
IT IS A PRIVATE SECTOR DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS. SO THERE IS
NO ADMINISTRATIVE. AND I GET A
SORT OF A KICK OUT OF THE
ANALYSIS SAYING IT COULD RESULT
IN UNKNOWN, POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT ANNUAL REDUCTION IN
PENALTY REVENUE RELATIVE TO
EXISTING LAW. SO THAT'S AN
INTERESTING WAY OF SAYING IF WE
PREVENT VIOLATIONS OF LAW, YOU
DO NOT GET THE PENALTIES
ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
VIOLATION. SO THIS SHOULD BE
REALLY CELEBRATED AS THE WAY TO
GO. AND IT HAS BEEN POLICY FOR
90 YEARS IN AMERICA TO PREFER
ARBITRATION AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RESOLUTION OVER
LITIGATION. SO ANY QUESTIONS BE
HAPPY TO DEAL WITH IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD SUMMARY. ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
EDDIE BERNACCHI, ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE OF THE PLUMBING,
HEATING PIPING INDUSTRY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS, PAUL GLADFELTER ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR JOE CRUZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL OF LABORERS, ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MATT CREMEANS, OPERATING
ENGINEER. STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS BRETT
BARRETT WITH UNITED CONTRACTORS
AND THE WESTERN LINE
CONSTRUCTORS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
WALKER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL AIR
CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS. THANK
YOU FOR THE BILL AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. SCOTT. GOVERNOR, BEHALF
OF THE CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE THIS THE AS I SAID
BEFORE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NOT WITH US HERE
TODAY. AND SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE,
WE'LL ALLOW YOU TO CONCLUDE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE IT UP AND THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ESTÁN.
OKAY, OKAY. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO RECESS FOR FIVE
MINUTES, AND WE'LL BE BACK WHEN
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR.
GOOD MORNING. SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO START RIGHT NOW.
SECRETARY, PLEASE ESTABLISH THE
QUORUM. CABALLERO. JONES HERE.
JONES. HERE. ASHBY. ASHBY. HERE
BECKER. BRADFORD BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. HERE. CIERTO WAHAB.
WAHAB HERE. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A QUORUM. I THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN BRIEFED BY
STAFF THAT ITEMS ONE, THREE AND
FOUR HAVE ALREADY BEEN PRESENTED
BY THE AUTHORS. OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SENATOR
ASHBY IS GOING TO PRESENT FOR
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WICKS. AND AS SOON
AS SENATOR ASHBY IS READY, WE
WILL RECEIVE HER PRESENTATION.
OKAY. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN
WICKS AND JACKSON, AB 518
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES, IN CONSULTATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS, TO DEVELOP A
FRAMEWORK TO CALCULATE WHO IS
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH AND TO USE
THAT INFORMATION TO PUBLISH DATA
AND METRICS TO DEVELOP TARGETED
OUTREACH STRATEGIES. CALFRESH IS
A 100% FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM,
SO IDENTIFYING AND IMPROVING
OUTREACH TO ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS IS A GOOD
INVESTMENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ASHBY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL 518? ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL 518?
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE DÍAS.
MEMBERS. ANY CONVERSATION ON AB
518. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION. DO YOU NEED TO CLOSE?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. BEAUTIFUL. CLOSE. OPEN.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. CABALLERO. JONES
AYE. JONES. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. CURRENT THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN. THE ROLL OPEN FOR
THE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THAT NEED
TO FIND THEIR WAY TO ROOM 112.
WHERE? THANK YOU. I LIKE THAT.
THAT WORKS, NEXT WE WILL TAKE UP
ITEM ONE FOR VOTE ONLY. ITEM ONE
PLEASE, SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. YOU NEED A MOTION. AB
224. I'M SORRY. DO WE NEED A
MOTION ON THAT? THE VICE VICE
CHAIR IS HELPING ME OUT OVER
HERE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION, SIR? SO MOVED. SO MOVED
BY MR. BRADFORD. 24 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. CABALLERO JONES, I JONES.
I ASHBY I ASHBY I BECKER.
BECKER. I BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
CIERTO WAHAB. WAHHAB AYE. FIVE 5
TO 0. KEEP THE ROLL OPEN FOR THE
REMAINING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM
THREE AB 535 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHIAVO. WE NEED A MOTION ON
THAT BILL, PLEASE. MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOTION BY SENATOR WAHAB.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB 535 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHIAVO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. JONES.
AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. CIERTO CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE SEVEN. THAT MOTION
HAS SEVEN. THAT MOTION HAS SEVEN
VOTES IN THE AFFIRMATIVE. IT
PASSES. MADAM CHAIR, WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO CONTINUE ON WITH THE
LAST ITEM, OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GAVEL BACK? OKAY. THANK YOU.
HAPPY TO DO IT. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM FOUR. ASSEMBLY BILL 1034 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. WE NEED
A MOTION ON THAT BILL. THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
READ THE MOTION FOR US, PLEASE?
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. CABALLERO
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. AYE. OH.
I'M SORRY. NO, I'M NÓ. JONES.
NO. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE. CIERTO. CIERTO. NO. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. FIVE. THANK YOU.
THAT MOTION HAS FIVE AFFIRMATIVE
VOTES. IT PASSES AND WILL MOVE
TO THE FLOOR. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
TO REOPEN. ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB
224. FOR ADDITIONAL VOTES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
CIERTO. CIERTO? AYE SEVEN. THAT
MOTION HAS SEVEN. ZERO IS SEVEN
VOTES IN THE AFFIRMATIVE. THAT
BILL MOVES TO THE FLOOR AS ITEM
NUMBER TWO. ASSEMBLY BILL 518.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. SECRETO 6 TO 0.
THAT BILL HAS SIX VOTES IN THE
AFFIRMATIVE. THAT BILL MOVES TO
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU EVERYBODY.
STAFF. GREAT JOB. CHAIRWOMAN
THANKS FOR LEADING A GREAT
MEETING THIS MORNING. APPRECIATE
IT. AFTER WAITING TO PRESENT
YOUR BILL, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS ADJOURNED.